>> Sean: A GREAT SHOW, I’VE
BEEN READING DR. SAFIRE’S NEW
BOOK, IT’S GREAT AND YOU CAN
LEARN A LOT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," MANY
AMERICANS ARE DESPERATELY
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES.
THEY WANT TO GET BACK TO THEIR
JOBS AND REOPEN BUSINESSES OF
COURSE IN A STATE OF ACADEMIC
AND SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE WAY.
WE CAN’T FORGET, NONSTOP AROUND
THE CLOCK, THEY HAVE BEEN
KEEPING THIS COUNTRY GOING.
THERE HAS BEEN NO SHUTDOWN OF
AMERICAN FARMERS OR THOSE
PACKERS OR OUR GREAT TRUCKERS OR
THE MANUFACTURERS OF MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT OR THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN STALKING GROCERY STORES
HERE AT THE EPICENTER OF
NEW YORK AND LONG ISLAND.
THEY WILL NEVER BE REOPENING.
WHY?
ALL AMERICAN HEROES WERE A
LIFELINE.
THEY STEPPED UP, THEIR INSPIRING
STORIES WERE INCREDIBLE.
THEY’VE BEEN SENDING OUR
MEDICINES IN LOGISTICALLY
HELPING ALL OF OUR HOSPITALS AND
BRAVE MEDICAL STAFF WITH THE
SAFETY EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN TIME AND
THEY GOT THEM.
JUST ONE EXAMPLE, 40 BROUGHT
SCUM EMPLOYEES IN PENNSYLVANIA
THEY LIVE AND STAY AT THEIR
WORKSITE, WORKING ALL DAY AND
WORKING ALL NIGHT.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY DESPERATELY NEEDED SUPPLIES
FOR N95 MASK FOR MEDICAL
WORKERS.
INCREDIBLE STORY, THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOU DO.
WHILE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ARE TIRELESSLY WORKING
HARD TO GET THIS COUNTRY AND
THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK,
SADLY, PREDICTABLE PEOPLE,
DEMOCRATS, THEIR ALLIES, THE
STATE RUN TELEVISION MEDIA MOB
ARE GLEEFULLY LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO POLITICAL HOLY BLUDGEON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SAME REPULSIVE PEOPLE AS USUAL.
WE WON’T SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
THEM RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE PUBLICLY STATING A
DESIRE TO USE THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND THE PANDEMIC AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO RESHAPE
AMERICA INTO A FAR LEFT AGREE
NEW DEAL SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
RECENTLY THE EVER CONFUSED
JOE BIDEN REMEMBER THAT WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT HELD A
FUND-RAISER.
DURING THAT FUND-RAISER HIGH
DOLLAR DONORS, "BECAUSE OF THE
COVID-19 CRISIS, PEOPLE ARE
REALIZING MY LORD, LOOK WHAT’S
UP POSSIBLE, AND HE SAID HE WAS
EXCITED BY THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO WHAT IS THE KIND OF
INSTITUTIONAL CHANGES THE EVER
FORGETFUL JOE IS EXCITED ABOUT
AS THE FORMER COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE, ED MARKEY, TWEETED
22 MILLION AMERICANS ARE OUT OF
WORK.
WE NEED TO RESCUE OUR ECONOMY
AND CREATE MILLIONS OF NEW UNION
JOBS.
WE NEED A GREEN NEW DEAL.
NO MORE PLANES, NO MORE
COMBUSTION ENGINES, NO MORE COWS
COWS, NO MORE OIL AND GAS.
AND OIL PRICES, WRITING YOU
ABSOLUTELY LOVE TO SEE IT.
THIS ALONE WITH RECORD LOW
INTEREST RATES MEANS IT’S THE
RIGHT TIME FOR A WORKER LED TO
MASS INVESTMENT AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SAVE OUR
PLANET.
CONGRESSWOMAN.
ARE YOU LET IGNORANT?
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
HIGH-PAYING CAREER JOBS WILL
DISAPPEAR IN A SECOND.
THAT’S THE LIFEBLOOD, AND THAT’S
FROM TEN YEARS TO 12 YEARS FROM
NOW.
FROM THAT END, SHE WANTS THEM TO
BOYCOTT WORKING.
>> WE TALK ABOUT THIS IDEA OF
REOPENING SOCIETY.
ONLY IN AMERICA DOES THE
PRESIDENT, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TWEETS ABOUT LIBERATION DOES HE
MEAN GOING BACK TO WORK.
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT
GOING BACK OR REOPENING, I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOULD JUST SAY,
NO.
WE ARE NOT GOING BACK TO THAT.
WE ARE NOT GOING BACK TO WORKING
70 HOUR WEEKS JUST SO THAT WE
CAN PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AND
NOT EVEN FEEL ANY SORT OF
SEMBLANCE OF SECURITY IN OUR
LIVES.
>> Sean: SHE’S NOT WORKING 70
HOURS PER WEEK, NANCY PELOSI HAS
EVERYBODY HOME.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ARE
EXPRESSING PLANS TO FLUSH
CAPITALISM AND THAT WILL BE IN
OUR CONSTITUTION AS WELL.
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT MAKES THIS
COUNTRY GREAT RIGHT DOWN THE
DRAIN AND THEN THEY ARE NOT
ALONE.
THE UNITED NATIONS TWEETING "IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC WHEN THE ECONOMICS TO
PACKAGES COMPOSED OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE DESIGNED AS A
REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR LONG-TERM
SYSTEMIC SHIFTS WITH GREEN
PACKAGES, AND EVEN FAKE NEWS
CNN, WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO BE
LEFT BEHIND?
FROM STAYING HOME TO KEEPING A
METERED DISTANCE OF ONE ANOTHER
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC HAS
DRASTICALLY CHANGED THE WAY WE
LIVE.
WHEN NOT DO THE SAME FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT?
AIRLINE INDUSTRIES, LET’S KICK
THEM IN THE TEETH WHILE THEY ARE
DOWN.
THEY ARE HOPING THAT OUR
LOCKDOWN LEADS TO A MAJOR RESET
AND PERMANENT CHANGES FOR
CLIMATE.
PEOPLE ARE STILL DYING, BUT
TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WORLD IS SUDDENLY
LEARNING WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF
HUMANS STOP POLLUTING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
>> PEOPLE SEE THIS AS A MAJOR
RESET FOR HUMANITY ON THE PLANET
PLANET.
THAT WILL EXPLORE THE BENEFITS
OF THE SHELTER-IN-PLACE ORDERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE DO HAVE SOME POSITIVE NEWS ON
THIS EARTH DAY.
>> THE CORONAVIRUS HAS BEEN A
TERRIBLE CRISIS, AND IT HAS
TURNED EVERYTHING UPSIDE DOWN.
BUT WE THOUGHT YOU WOULD WANT TO
KNOW ABOUT SOME SURPRISING WAYS
THAT IT’S ACTUALLY HELPING OUR
PLANET.
>> THIS IS A GREAT MOMENT OF
PAUSE FOR ALL OF US, AND WE
REALIZE THAT OUR CHOICES DO
IMPACT THE ENVIRONMENT AROUND
US.
>> HOW DO I SAY THIS NICELY?
IN THIS PROFESSION, WE HAVE SOME
REALLY DUMB PEOPLE.
ANYWAY, THAT WOULD SURELY
DESTROY OUR WAY OF LIFE AND PUT
MANY AMERICANS OUT OF WORK.
TRYING TO GET THE COUNTRY UP AND
RUNNING AGAIN WITH EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY, MONEY ON THE LEFT, THE
MOB IN MEDIA TRYING TO USE
CORONAVIRUS AS WHAT IS A COLD,
CALCULATED POLITICAL WEAPON TO
ADVANCE THEIR RADICAL AGENDA.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS
THEY HAVE USED IT THE COURSE TO
BLUDGEON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OF COURSE HE’S A RACIST, IS
ENOUGH OVERCOME A FEAR MONGER,
AND POLICY USING THE EMERGENCY
GOVERNMENT RELIEF PACKAGES AS A
PERSONAL PIGGY BANK FOR HER
FAVORITE LIBERAL CAUSES,
WITHHOLDING MONEY FOR HOSPITALS,
WORKERS, SMALL BUSINESS AND
LARGE BUSINESS.
WHY, SO SHE CAN GET $150 MILLION
TO THE NATIONAL ENDOWMENT OF
ARTS AND HUMANITIES.
25 MILLION FOR THE KENNEDY
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER,
75 MILLION FOR PBS AND NATIONAL
PROPAGANDA RADIO.
SHE ATTEMPTED TO CHANGE ELECTION
AND IMMIGRATION LAWS ON TOP OF
IT.
REMEMBER, WORKERS WERE WEEDING
AND NEEDED THE HELP.
FOR THE PAST WEEK SHE HAD HELD
UP FUNDING FOR SMALL BUSINESSES,
TWO GAMES AND SOME KIND OF
POLITICAL LEVERAGE YET AGAIN.
ULTIMATELY SHE CAVED AND FUNDED
THE PROGRAM AND THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ARE NOT
HAPPY.
SHE TOOK 5 MINUTES AWAY FROM
EATING HER DESIGNER ICE CREAM
COME TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DON’T KNOW WHAT’S IN THE
PACKAGE YET, WE ONLY KNOW WHAT’S
BEEN REPORTED.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU’RE HEARING
FROM ALL OF US ON THE CALL IS
THAT WE HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
GIVING AWAY LEVERAGE NOW WITHOUT
GETTING SOME OF THE PRIORITIES
THAT WE NEED.
>> SMALL BUSINESSES IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE DESPERATE, MANY ARE
TAKING PAY CUTS AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO KEEP THEIR EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYED.
THAT CONGRESSWOMAN IS ONLY
CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING A
POLITICAL LEVERAGE.
SICK, UGLY, TWISTED, RADICAL,
REPULSIVE, THAT’S YOUR NEW MOTTO
MODERN EXTREME SOCIALIST PARTY,
THE MOB.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING OUT FOR
YOU, YOUR GREEN NEW DEAL IS
APPARENTLY MORE IMPORTANT.
PELOSI NEEDS TO GET ON HER BIG
CARBON FOOTPRINT PRIVATE JET AND
SHE CAN BRING HER DESIGNER
ICE CREAM AND HER BIG EXPENSIVE
FREEZER WITH HER.
IF SHE DOESN’T WANT TO BRING IT
I WILL MAIL IT TO HER, I WILL
FIND A WAY.
GET BACK TO WASHINGTON, SHE
NEEDS TO GET BACK TO WORK
PASSING CORONAVIRUS LEGISLATION,
BECAUSE EVERYONE ELSE IS
WORKING.
THE FARMERS ARE FARMING, THE
PACKERS ARE PACKING, THE TRUCK
DRIVERS DELIVERING.
THE GUYS IN NEW YORK,
LONG ISLAND, THEY ARE STOCKING
THE SHELVES.